appreciate it thanks buddy of your guys
is uh your guys's team we all know
work is the right to work wait why is it
work
otherwise we made oh us
is your name woad woad it
to scratch your tummy are you [ __ ]
that cat sounds like wade's getting
jealous yeah he is getting jealous
because i'm touching
his [ __ ]
[Applause]
i mean i'm
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i forgot i was on wednesday oh that's
that's all i gotta do is drop the fire
the fire cat jokes that mark comes right
screaming back
yeah no sorry bob sorry about friendship
over i'm with wade now
you're really you're hard to read
sending mixed signals here look man
look unless you give another slang or
like that i i will not be on your team
uh-oh listen archie we're on the same
team now you hear me
you get him you get him bud no no you
get them weighed
listen i can protect you see what your
other sides look like
all right uh all right archie you could
do this
oh buddy that's not yes
listen the numbers are hard okay you're
a cat i forgive you
oh we're going back i guess
all right wade has a purple and wild oh
mark
you don't know why am i saying that out
loud come on archie wade has a purple in
a while don't give it to him
wade i'm really sorry no you wouldn't
that would not
even i would not i wouldn't do it
i wouldn't do it i think you should
probably do it mark just to see what
happens nice work archie nice work
nice workout archery he set me up and i
kicked it through the goal post
the ever moving goal post i just no
marks
this is a big play no mark's making
movies yeah yeah no it's wait it's all
part of it i can see i can't see what's
coming but i can smell
big moves in the future for sure yeah
see wait now it's all coming together i
knew what she was going to do look what
you have in your hand wade look at how
you're about to just dominate the
competition
yes oh
[Music]
that was a little slow you could pick
faster next time keep the hype going but
yeah it's fine i'm still
processing the plus five i got when i
had uno from my teammate
no what that's not what happened no no
it's part of the grand plan there's the
scheme
there's a shenanigan occurring this is
there's hijinks being played out
bob bob is going to be so mad in a
little bit
so mad you're going to be so mad yeah
hit him again wade
nice yes all right all right
wait wait no hit him you got him
all right he's got the knowledge and the
plays
and oh buddy that doesn't work out very
well for me that's
horrible i feel like we're not we're not
working together as a team at all archie
i get the sense that i'm the only one
who's in on this bit
all right i can't be right back to the
colorful realm
first i love how the music changes i
haven't really noticed
when we go to this realm the music is
all dark and i like this version of
reality better than the other version
which it's just all right all right
we're back to a good color
hey archie yeah calm down there cat
all right all right make some play
oh now we're gonna make some plays
here's your play buddy
oh good that's that's that's
is that not the color you have done
all right all right mark yes are you
ready to receive my love yeah
receive it i am receiving it ah
yeah no this isn't good pay it forward
archie listen okay yeah they can take it
for the team that's
that's a good soldier hey look at that
wait now let's talk about this colored
it's okay wait i'll save you thank ooh
wade has blue and red ah he has two
blues and a red i've seen them i seen
them
but i have this
he does have that he does
okay for the victory
archie is the best teammate how did you
lose with him wayne he's so good he's
skillful
he's really good i won and then you guys
accused me of saying
wait i know why didn't you work with
this cat this game was a genius
i gave you that plus five i thought you
would know what to do with it
yeah i i did i drew five more cards no
bob i can't work with this guy i saw the
play mark i saw
thank you at least someone made it you
want to mix it up i think you and i
should team up
each other's eyes i can't stop looking
at the way your lips look you know
yeah i can't stop looking at that
countdown on your face
never mind now i can see your face again
i my hands were completely off the
keyboard in mouse
get a mark they might have been down my
pants sorry i i teamed back up but with
the wrong thing that was like
three seconds before i was trading r g r
g
r g archie i'm setting you up wade
i'm sorry all right i got it she screwed
me over the place
you're coming you got this blade a
little bit
that's a good card you want that card
that was a good draw positive draw
positive draw
hey challenge me
i will ah
man actually that art is the only thing
i can play right now so i guess it was
good how do you have so many cards that
are all useless hey look at this guy
great question i don't know if the back
side of my deck looks good but the front
side is pretty much like the sahara
desert no the back side does not look
great well that's
great dude i don't know why you did that
okay yes yes yes yes
wow okay wow sure
[Applause]
no i'm challenging archie's are lying
never mind i just got all the others
never lies
cats always tell the truth no cats
always land on their feet
that they can lie as much as they want i
don't think that's true
never forgets an elephant always lands
on his feet
yes teamwork yes two cats in a bush is
worth
three in a barrel you get five for ten
if you put a million cats in a room with
a million typewriters
yes uh yeah an infinite amount of time
eventually you have a bunch of
[ __ ] covered typewriters that checks up
okay
what are you gonna what are you going to
do what are you going to do pathetic
path pitiful
you know what we need more we need more
teamwork wade yeah well it's
i haven't played in 30 years yes what do
you think
there's going to be one good one never
mind so
yeah do it again do it again
all right oh well what the archie's got
the place look at this
five-head move he's playing over here
kenny we can't even keep up with what's
happening
yeah on the bright side i've got so many
cards now i can't possibly lose
action number one going on on your
teammate there mark
thanks man together we're like five for
ten heads
how are all of my cards yeah i'm
whipping it right back
well i have one of those i guess yeah
don't get too excited too yet you're
just playing right into archie's master
plan
i'm terrified of archie he definitely
knows what's happening in evil
yeah yeah oh yeah oh i know i think
archie has an orange
i have one i don't even not even look
brain plays
take that archie
all right you may think you've won this
one but i know archie he's giving me the
signals
yeah he's giving you the the blank stare
the dead eyes look he's doing it
doing it and he's he's all forward back
yes
back and forth and back and forth
yes it's all according to plan flopping
around
like a like a bunch of nudists at the
beach i didn't look again at what archie
has so we're flying behind here
blue mark's not going to do
scene that's one of those ones where i'm
a little afraid you might have had a
stroke
make sure you can lift both your arms up
over your head real quick for me
[Laughter]
i was so excited my mouth decided not to
worry you know your insults aren't as
biting these days and i don't know why
oh just you wait you'll feel the
bite soon wow man aren't just got this
deck counted out
he knows all the ends and the outs he
knows the little crevices
archie knows he smells them coming down
nose
he's got yellow weight i remember to
look it's yellow
or is it okay
that's not what you want to see
[Music]
oh that's not what you want it's yellow
don't make it yellow anything but yellow
a good one good one yeah i didn't know
what number it was i was hoping it
wasn't four
good one four i can't remember a color
and a number at the same time so
all right we'll have to go back to the
other side and figure that out
what the frick what your mic
just cut out and you were just like
i don't know what my mic does you can't
tell me how my mic is
that wasn't the play well we know archie
doesn't have green
oh i knew it i didn't wait no no
god yes no
i'm
wait did you do that i did that yeah
that was the most
savage [ __ ] oh my god too late mark was
already on top
you know mark is a terrible teammate
holy crap
uh archie if that costs you the win i am
big son what's wrong with you man
big sorry archie i'm big sorry damn
damn oh you're not settling damn you
know
it just show goes to show i'll stab
anybody in the back and i won't even
think about it before i do it it'll be
instinctual betrayal is in my blood
that's that's concerning i don't like it
i will take this one archie
because i owe you i owe you
[Laughter]
you fool what why is he drawing no
archie i did this for you
archie
man archie really did not see the
the plan that you had i threw him off
his rhythm
all right we gotta go back why do we
have to go back
i don't know this is pretty good oh wait
go back i want to go back i want to go
back
i had restraint i think i have the
superior teammate
oh man he double hated me just like that
i mean i made it yellow too i had the
big brain played
you had the absolute killer crush uh
can you stop complimenting each other
for one moment
wait it was so good what you did was
brilliant
and also amazing it can't be brilliant
and amazing
there's no way bryan is a
it's possible but i'm saying oh you're
making a bald joke
you are correct i'm proud of my lack of
hair
good job buddy good job man thank you i
don't know what happened i zoned out for
a long time that i heard bald jokes so i
just
i thought figures about me you're just
basking in the glow the compliments and
just like
oh yeah oh flip flop
oh yeah oh yeah if i have two
ones can i tape those together and play
them as a two
sure i'd say yeah i couldn't find the
button
wait i see those plus fives in you we
are not going to the other dimensions i
don't know which ones are let's go
hang out on the other side of them is
this one of them
no you're good you're good is this one
of them
nope you're good no oddly enough no
they're your
middle cards buddy don't you worry about
it all right
i'm gonna play i'm gonna live
dangerously dude
what do you think of that cat i thought
so
you know i'm also on archie's team so i
could be a threat if you yeah
you think about that it's the only real
threat no if you think about it i could
work here
i could i could also i've won a game
before i've done it
no no i've i've done i've won games
oh no no i mean i have you can't deny it
no
no i don't know i don't think that's
right i'm a player in this
too three there were all those twos
waiting you're gonna put a three in
there
i had a two ready to go can you put a
three in there a threat
mark no wait exact reason right there no
number two you can't no you can't even
get two strands four
taking a poo look at that look at this
guy with double digit cards now
look at you
he's just lashing out now he has no
strategy no i
have a plan no threat whatsoever coming
from that guy
i have a plan ah sure sure is that why
is that why you have 11 cards
you know that's a lot of talk for
someone smells smooth
so i hope you heard me you you got to
give yourself over your head
your hands over your head listen there
was a there was a stinging insult in
there and you just couldn't hear it
ah well you're definitely right i could
not bathing retribution
you should be very and you should be
crying right now
uh we'll see how i feel after i win
yeah right wade won't let you he's too
greedy
if wade wins i win i'm trying to get him
to the finish line here look at this
look at this teamwork yeah we gotta say
marcino
sit and watch no oh no no no no
no stop wait wait uh
[Music]
that jump play dreamwork what archie on
the ropes
archie thought he had you with the flip
but i didn't see what was i was also a
contender
i was close look at you in your fourth
position you just calm down
you almost got the bronze medal i would
have jesus christ my hand
what the hell oh i thought you meant
your actual hand like in real life no no
look you can see the earth weight i
guess i wish i could
show you my hand you know how you made
fun of me for having a three this feels
like compensation
i have five threes
it's like i didn't have that three one
time like never again
i will not be betrayed good choice bob
good choice
i got you uh buddy we're all we're all
on equal footing now there's that
joy no teams anymore
they're either dude i'm gonna freaking
win dude i'm gonna win freeze come out
of your hoo-ha
listen my hoo-ha has storage capacity
all right i was doing a bit he was doing
his house
that's a two it's not supposed to have
twos in there look like two
so kind of liar look what are you some
kind of
sociopath yes
yes and where did that bring you back to
us
come on do it for me do it to me do it
on me it would have been a
big brain play what it would have been a
big brain play to like pick a different
card and bet on you
colored card to bet on you to not what
are just what what is happening archie
just robbed me
yeah we still won no
wade you lost friends i
hate you i had friends i'm sorry wade i
didn't mean that
wait you didn't mean that i didn't lose
friends or you didn't mean that you hate
me i don't hate you
but you lost friends no we're not
friends you just don't hate me yeah
isn't that pretty good that's pretty by
the way random note
what have you seen all the random tick
tocks of us going around
with like the yeah wait you're my friend
now and i'm like i have a friend
what no we're on tick tock what well
it's mark and i from like raft or
something it's mark and i talking about
not plus well it's it's from one of our
things but it's just like three lines
it's mark saying like
hey wait you're my friend now and i go i
have a friend
what what you have to download so i can
see what these kids are doing
i don't know why that's a thing i've
gotten so many tweets of different tick
tock videos of us having that little
conversation what if i what so what do i
search for markiplier
i don't know oh i'm playing a game hang
on whatever this is not interesting
anymore
what is this uno garbage mark did you
see a secret message in the discord a
few minutes ago
no i was just quiet wait why didn't you
say that was a secret message why
couldn't you have just relayed that to
me
i wanted a moment of sounding cool is
that so much
yes all right what was happening in this
game okay it's
flip mark what it's me i thought i
thought that was on someone else
oh all right here here's the audio what
what what are you talking
a
about
yeah you and me we're friends now that's
it okay man
that's not real that's a slapper of a
tick tock that's what i don't
that's so dumb why no you just
understand what's cool wait that's the
problem
i guess i the music just makes it well
the music is
someone had it i guess but like why is
that i don't know why it's a thrill dude
i don't know i know i said some i talked
some [ __ ] to you before but holy crap
man you gotta calm down
ah archie okay
well get a bottle let's send it all the
way around to mark
no i can't get it off can i say no can i
say no now
come on
[Applause]
oh my god the back of your cards mark
what the hell all right
what does it look like what is on the
back of my cards am i killing it
am i killing it am i killing it right
now am i about to kill it
why do i i don't want to do this can i
stop going around
i just draw more cards every time this
is the worst situation
this is not ideal you're slowly
accumulating cards and playing that
thing that
sucks
oh i still don't have this color guys if
i was
apparently doing so hot to trot
oh whoa i call you nice i don't know if
you got him or i got him i got him i got
him i got him you didn't get anything
i clicked on it no i was over there no i
don't know
anymore what was in the other world
what's on my cards
no well you had a couple of good cards
did i lose my good cards
wait yeah you played them like an idiot
this is pretty good yeah it was better
though if you can believe it
no i can't
um listen aren't you oh
oh wow well that worked i guess
i i i just you know i didn't want you to
get hurt by that
i was gonna uno him but yeah i didn't
realize no
guys no wait stop hang on
go ahead and hmm uh i'll risk it no
no no no no
i thought you know maybe i could get
around and then they
look guys i'll give you another chance
all right good you should you should
know
that i wait i wanted to play the other
one
well what should i know though you can't
say something like that you should know
not tell me what i need to know you
should know that you are a fool
and you will be defeated by me
i don't like the sound that's not good
oh oh
crap well i'm gonna draw cards because i
want to and not because i have to
right like me you're like me i'm doing
this by
choice that's what i did you really just
give it to him mark what color you want
i could take anything
you know what i have yeah well the one
thing for sure but
nah i'll draw yes
we're gonna take a gamble here uh i read
archie's mind
doesn't have a red okay we know red's
safe so there's a
i will test the fade again yes hey
look at that eight ah
okay why blue get away from blue my
luck cannot last it lasts
whoa come on that's what i thought oh
that's unfair you should take your turn
where did that bring you back
yes yes yeah yes
play nice play nice
wow all right
now you guys don't know what i mean
with the big the big cajones playing it
blue but that doesn't even make any
sense
the big cajones but making it blue
literally makes no sense because you
were so upset about blue yeah
you'll never know my plans he
[Music]
that is the good that's the stuff that i
like how about
red red's interesting oh
oh oh oh oh
oh or oh oh
oh oh that's going on a long time there
buddy
oh it sure was all right
okay oh good still nectar oh nothing's
happening to you stop saying oh
oh sorry oh no
[Music]
wouldn't be that way would it wouldn't
work out perfectly for me
no this is interesting oh from first
place
to third place you know what
you did bob you are going to suffer my
wrath
that's what i've decided likely you're
going to suffer my wrath
you're going to suffer my brain i'm
fearing it yeah well start
fearing it that's not good i play this
[Music]
good he moved so fast my eyes couldn't
track it
no stop stop thanks for
protecting me not teammate wayne
oh all right you're welcome
you're gonna suffer my wrath bob you're
gonna suffer my wrath
my wrath unless i play one of these
oh man my wrath
ah cool card yeah did you have fun with
it did you have fun i did
that was fun oh cool card
right in the middle
send it around archie send it around
[Music]
damn can you make that a six mark do you
have any more wrath
um always for you well no no
do do it the other way wrath him uh well
i can do this
i do feel somewhat wrathed and then i
could do this
wow all right well uh i guess bob you
got what you wanted
my wrath
that's kind of not what i intended my
wrath
[Music]
[Music]
you